people all over the world are waking up
so now we got just an awesome array of
videos all over the world uh of freedom
convoys breaking out everywhere here's
israel first the left loves israel don't
they now they're really gonna love
israel
[Music]
[Music]
oh
let me go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
so to be very clear i mean new zealand
new zealand definitely wins for like
coolest protesters uh but what you saw
there were israel germany france
australia italy new zealand this is
obviously going on in canada i have a
sense that maybe it's going to start in
the united states and some of the blue
states as well
but
notice there was nothing burning in the
background
there was no looting
there were no signs to kill trans people
or whatever it is that justin trudeau
has been lying about these are just
people like you
that's what they are you person watching
this right now if any of the stuff that
i talk about here means anything to you
then those people are fighting for you
and they're fighting for you now all
over the globe and it is absolutely
incredible so now we've got some video
we'll bring it back to canada for a
second this is a brian peckford he is
the last living signer of canada's
charter of rights and freedoms the last
living one he gave an
absolutely i mean just a moving
like actually sit back and watch this
speech it's just incredible we're not
going to allow this nation on the
northern part
of north america to go down the drain
because we have people who've gotten
hungry for power and have discarded the
individual freedoms that you and i own
[Music]
[Applause]
they are ours
there's none two of us the same that's
why individual rights and freedoms are
so important right because it's you as a
person
you as an individual not you as a family
not you as a group
okay not you as part of some other
organization not you is part of the
province it's you as an individual
canadian possess these rights
that's what's important
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i recommend you find the the full speech
if you haven't seen the full speech you
can find it on youtube and on rumble i'm
sure
um it's you it's you
you get it it's you that can fix this
what if we all have more power than they
want us to think we have
i suspect that we do
and that's why they want to arrest these
good people and find these good people
and make sure that they can't crowdfund
because they fear the individual because
you know what happens when the
individual looks out for themselves the
individual finds other people who look
out for themselves and then you got two
individuals and they kind of got some
stuff in common and they might start
building something and it might be good
and it might not need them
and i think we've all had enough of them
okay so that's what we're gonna keep
doing we're gonna keep pushing on this
and keep pushing on it and keep pushing
on it